congratulations on with love listen this
kicks off with a christmas episode which
no better time to watch that than right
now but the thing that i took away from
watching this is
this is just full of joy there really
isn't that background of trauma it's
happiness it's silliness it's love is
that something that you loved about this
project
absolutely you know
i love the drama aspect of our stories
too but we deserve to also see ourselves
in just a
joy-filled project of happiness and love
we deserve that too so when i saw this
script i was like right away
i have to have this role
and then um with the call back and when
i found out i got it um i was just so
grateful i love this character they are
so similar to me outside of the doctor
part i could never do that i have a weak
stomach but outside of that
we're so similar and and we deserve to
see ourselves be loved
absolutely this cast is fantastic and i
have a feeling walking into this there
may have been a bit of nerves for you
was there that moment for yourself where
you're like okay isis do not f this up
um i think seeing some of the cast there
were so many of my castmates who i
watched them in their shows so i was
just thinking oh my god i'm a fan of you
i love shadowhunters i love ugly like i
love this i love that um but everybody
was so sweet and we really got along
well and that made it really easy the
first day when we were all together i
was kind of quiet like
you know we had this church scene that
first opens the show
and i was a little nervous but after
that that made me feel really welcome
and and once i got comfortable that's it
because i could talk okay
and the thing i also love about this is
all too often you know media has gotten
better at embracing trans individuals
and sharing those stories but sometimes
those stories are just
you know the waitress at a bar or the
best friend who has you know like two
words within within a scene but these
are main characters you are a main
character is that what you are hoping to
see more of in the future
absolutely and even what you said about
the waitress or two lines we just even
got to that point because when i first
started acting what like 12 years ago it
was the two lines but it was just like
streetwalker number one streetwalker
number two and it's just like
we we have all types of careers you know
we can be everything i personally know
two trans doctors so
we deserve to see ourselves in the
forefront as well
and to have these fully realized
characters and we deserve that
i'm gonna have a bit of a moment here
because i grew up watching america's
next top model i really did and i
remember your season
i feel like most of us did like let's be
real whether you love it or hate it love
tyra i hate her everybody watched at
some point it was that show
it was that show and
seeing you on there isis was like holy
bleep um this is some progress you know
what i mean this is showing where we
could go uh you know now you're moving
into this acting world are you feeling
like your career is heading where you
want and you are kind of leaving behind
that reality television star title
oh that that's a really good question
that's a complex answer
i'm gonna try to answer it quickly
because i can talk for a while yes i did
want to leave the reality because i feel
like for me it was really hard to be
taken seriously as the actress um i've
been acting since 2009 like shortly
after i left top model i said if i can
do this i can do everything so i i did a
few off-broadway plays and i went to a
short film and i ended up
filming an indie film in the philippines
in 2011.
and at that point i was like i really
want to pursue this but there were no
real opportunities happening so i had to
kind of just grab them as they come it
was usually the two lines
this person that person number one
number two you know and more so within
the last few years we really just
started to to really dig into these
things these characters all these roles
that we were able to get
but for so long there were no real
opportunities so i kind of made it work
i've always wanted to and i said okay i
have to really take this seriously
and i did another reality show strut um
when i first moved to la but i was like
okay this is making it hard for them to
take me serious
so i stopped for a while i really
focused just on the acting because the
more opportunities started to come and
more complex characters started to
develop
and now more recently um i did start uh
having general meetings because i would
love to
in a reality space get into hosting or
judging that that's
a direction i would love to go where i
feel like i could still do that and and
still have my
booming acting career um
but but i would love to now
full circle moment uh get into judging
and and or hosting because hosting is
something i love to do anyway a lot of
people are looking back at top model and
flagging a lot of things that are very
unappropriate like even myself when i
watch it back and i'm seeing these clips
on twitter i'm like
holy
hell how did this ever fly you know what
i mean when you look back at the show
for yourself was it a positive
experience for you because i can only
imagine being a trans woman in that
situation like we said we weren't seeing
that on television at that time was it a
positive experience now that you've had
that separation looking back
um for the most part i mean there were
some moments of course that i wish could
have been different
um i get from their perspective i'm
trying to catch everything um i do wish
it was a few things that
that were
handled differently um
but for the most part i i love the
experience you have to understand too i
um they picked me out of i was in a
shelter uh that was my first time buying
a bikini buying uh
uh luggage getting on an airplane going
to la so i really took this experience
as
how often is somebody like me going to
have this opportunity i i was
full-heartedly in it wholeheartedly in
it so every little thing they would go
to bed i would still be in the pool
because i have a pool in my in my
backyard you know i'm in this mansion
like every little aspect i took when we
would get hair and makeup i would ask
questions and that's how i learned how
to really execute good makeup and then
becoming a makeup artist myself like
every single i think it really depends
on your mindset
i went to school on a full tuition
scholarship for design that i won and i
remember
i was still the one in the front of the
class learning everything even though i
wasn't paying because i didn't want my
scholarship to be taken and there were
people in there that
had loans and parents would pay for them
and they would just be us through and
not do it so i really just depend
with any experience it really depends on
how you go into it yes granted there are
some things that were problematic but if
i go in it knowing that i'm going to
soak up every single thing i need for my
future i don't know why i'm going to
need this but this is what i want to do
and i'm going to soak it up there are
lessons i learned now i know how to do
teleprompter work i know how to do
posting work i'm acting i'm a
spokesperson
i'm doing influencer work i'm doing all
these things that i learned and top
model and i think that was because i was
the person at the front of the class
taking notes and really paying attention
so
i think for anybody you can pick and
find things but for me i'm going to be
i'm always so grateful because i can
look at it and see now where i am and
how the lessons i learned during the
show even the things that weren't so
good even not speaking up when i should
have you know because i was worried i
would get booted out and speaking of now
and learning how to boss up now these
are all things that i i literally
contribute to being on the show and i
would have never thought in all sectors
of what we learned i would be using that
in my career
yeah it's incredible the trajectory of
your career so you should be so proud of
yourself it's been a long journey i was
just standing in another interview
i just got another mattress a year and a
half ago like i was renting a room in a
house with a whole bunch of roommates so
i didn't know just to save money
that's how to keep uh moving apartments
and like re-furnishing so i said you
know what i'm gonna put my sofa from my
last apartment in my room because i just
had this room in here and i'm not gonna
be here long it'll be fine i'll step on
that sofa for three years so i moved and
then i just recently moved again and i i
have a mattress again now but people see
you on a red carpet and think like it's
all good because i know how to put
myself together something i have to
learn through being poor
my background is also designed so i know
how to pick up my outfits and i would do
my hair do my makeup and i know how to
put myself together but
it has been a long journey and i'm so
thankful that i didn't give up because
through the years has been so many
moments where i wanted to
and but i can say that with this past
year i finally
have felt like i'm getting to a place
where people assumed i've been the whole
time and not in a way where i tried to
make it myself look like you know i was
never one of those people that tried to
make myself look like i was something
else because i would always share my
story if someone asked like how
difficult it has been but i'm just so
grateful that with trajectory i'm
finally starting to get to a place where
i'm just so excited and so grateful and
so thankful that i didn't give up any
other year because i would definitely
not be where i am talking to you right
now